welcome to this video playing Michael
Hennigan international master Hennigan
okay is playing the reversed pilk pills
I don't know I always like that for for
black and white s absolutely absolutely
nothing here um yeah d 4 hmm this should
be 695 is probably stupid and I don't
know about the form okay just keep it
simple nothing super great but
definitely here also nothing create for
white Joe D takes I guess I mean night
takes is just giving me a better center
so I mean can do that wyd would probably
not be much worse but definitely not
better okay um castles probably yeah
Bishop to e6 yeah I can do that or age 6
yeah it's hard to play without age 6 s
position always okay that's it's a nice
idea okay so h6 wasn't very precise but
look do you wanna it's a bit a bit
unfortunate yeah okay if I go Queenie
eight he's got night be five on my D 5
coming so I must play 90 form but I
really don't want to do yeah maybe you
can even take her and use the pin at the
end page six how stupid what this
I mean it's a totally nothing position
for off a white no okay they always hate
that if you get into trouble if the
opponent is playing like super harmless
then you play some nonsense and get
yourself into big trouble here yet again
it can just take on d1 or whatever but
not age six hmm okay yeah the question
is yeah exactly and Bishop takes Bishop
Teague's and 95 this this kind of stuff
is probably just working
maybe I can take on f 2 we are sort of a
desperado fashion this also just not be
5 or not each way yeah but I think here
maybe I have some possibilities fire
when I can go see 5 why not now that
that's not that's not super convincing
Hawaii Bishop g4 sf3 unfortunately but I
have 96 I can just cover them
maybe that's not too bad I don't don't
really see that that tactic lock takes
takes Knight takes Knight takes bishop
takes Bishop takes Queen somewhere
working I can always take f2 and then
taking on f 2 37 something like that it
should be okay and if I get one or two
more moves like Queen B 6 i'm even
better so with this pawn hear me yeah
i'm not sure if better but i don't
really have i have no problems what's
alive if he's not able to punish me
right now um I'm definitely okay um yeah
I guess with the porno hmm interesting
yes he wants to I assume he wants to
prevent my queen moves and at the same
time at active form
ok
okay let's let's do that I don't really
know that some very tricky but taking be
to now as well also might get this porn
back I can take their I mean I can
that's not really great take be tuned
Bishop before this kind of business it's
not not equalizing but the cam probably
not not a very very big choice here I
cannot take with the queen of course the
rookie is hanging help oh no our the
game yeah what a game I looked III at
the resign I have no no way to save the
nine ninety-two we just move the king 96
it can just take is six maybe even way
to again night is six I can take d 8
this is the easiest check here
any any trick or something ah whatever
what a bad game time warning yeah it's
lost in any way it does not matter
really Luke th is easy black resign wow
that hurt that really hurt first I
overlooked this is quincy one idea which
is yeah really bad to overlook and then
somehow it wasn't so bad i thought at
least so i know this t3 yeah one still
and i'm still in another trouble here
and this is not AI mean bishop divorce
just losing I wanted to take with the
Queen obviously on d4 but my rook hangs
on a fate so yeah I needed to go here
this is just of course bad for me he's
got all the activity he's got all the
activity yeah I mean the main issue is
that age six is idiotic simply something
like that is just absolutely nothing for
white it's it's it's it's just okay for
like nothing nothing special going on I
can possibly get in c6 here to to
control those squares and this knight on
c3 is not really well placed so this is
it's just an equal position it's nothing
nothing happening I really had a
I didn't think about this one this is
strong I need to attend to this really
only this move and then he go goes to d1
with tempo and there this is just bad
because it loses straight away I also
don't have this move I mean maybe I have
this move but it looks it looks very
ugly this kind of business maybe it's
better yeah and here the problem is
white is just better developed and if we
have really thought the worst should be
over maybe i can now i'm still not good
to them well developed maybe maybe I can
improve somehow with this life is doing
the same i have b 6 available yeah maybe
i can somehow hang on but the whole the
whole problem was starting with this age
6 move which allowed quincy one which
was just just good for wide okay thanks
for watching